with two broken legs the mother remains
in the hospital but with a broken ankle
the driver was wheelchair into court
Tuesday morning as legal proceedings
begin and the family prepares for a
funeral
the 25 year old Khalia Manning battered
by the crash She's accused of causing a
suspected DUI that killed two-year-old
Rose and three-year-old Taylor Wilmer
the toddlers of her sister 23 year old
renisha Washington who was the passenger
the Declaration of arrest shows Manny
was driving with a blood alcohol level
nearly two and a half times Nevada's
limit after splitting a bottle of
tequila with a friend we want to have
our own private accident investigator
attorney Dan Winder now represents them
both saying he received these cases
Monday night and plans for another
investigator to reconstruct the accident
Bale currently stands at a hundred
thousand dollars for Manning and 25 000
for Washington amounts the attorney says
will likely be posted we're gonna ask
that they be released so they can
neither one of them have any real prior
record they've lived her all their lives
they have family support and they have
to bury their loved one they have to
bury their these two children but the
cases may not stay there the DA's office
indicating in court they may be elevated
to the grand jury the woman's mother
declining to speak to eight news now
outside court Tuesday but their attorney
says we need to withhold judgment until
all of the evidence is in until the
investigation is complete
well he has the driver and the passenger
both suffered from internal bleedings
now among other complications the mother
faces two counts of abuse and neglect
resulting in death and as far as the
driver they face 11 different charges
they're scheduled back in court in two
weeks